if you thought it was wild and
unprecedented when donald trump attacked
his own former vice president mike pence
for not trying to overturn an election
that he lost that is nothing
compared with what donald trump did
yesterday clearly enamored with vladimir
putin and remember
trump has said he has fallen in love
with dictators before and then we fell
in love right that was about kim jong-un
trump enamored with vladimir putin
yesterday
called
genius putin's invasion of ukraine
using the pretext of recognizing the
independence of those two regions
smart and savvy
guys trump is in love trump is in love
he loves putin
and he loves the invasion trump appeared
yesterday on the clay travis and buck
sexton show i don't know what that is
but trump
clearly doing lots of right wing shows
and here is what he had to say and he's
just smitten with vladimir putin we know
russia has said that they are
recognizing to break away regions of
ukraine and now this white house is
stating that this is an invasion
that's a strong word what went wrong
here what has the current
occupant of the oval office done that he
could have done differently well what
went wrong was a rigged election so
first of all
there is no question that trump can
answer without mentioning the big lie
that he actually won okay so let's
that's not what we're gonna focus today
what went wrong is a candidate that
shouldn't be there
and a man that has no concept of what
he's doing i went in yesterday and there
was a television screen and i said this
is genius
putin
declares
a big portion of the ukraine of ukraine
putin declares it as independent oh
that's wonderful so putin
is now saying it's independent a large
section of ukraine
i said how smart is that
and he's going to go in and be a
peacekeeper
he is smitten now some of you have
pointed out
trump sort of seems to be using a tone
that suggests he recognizes
the cynical nature of what putin is
doing and i agree i agree tr trump sees
what putin is doing but he still is so
impressed i'm not saying he likes it but
he's so
impressed with how putin has done this
that's the strongest peace for us we
could use that on our southern border
that's the strongest peace force i've
ever seen there were more army tanks
than i've ever seen they're going to
keep peace all right no but think of it
here's a guy who's very savvy i know i'm
very very savvy very well very very well
by the way this never would have
happened with us had i been in office
not even thinkable this would never have
happened but here's a guy that says you
know
i'm going to declare
a big portion of ukraine independent he
used the word independent and we're
going to go out and we're going to go in
and we're going to help keep peace
you got to say that's pretty savvy so
trump of course
an undertone of what putin is doing i
would not have allowed it to happen
but he is just in love with vladimir
putin can you imagine what fox news and
the other republicans would be doing if
biden or some other democratic leader
called what putin was doing genius smart
savvy trump is basically saying putin is
super smart and this is all genius and
it never would have happened if i was in
the white house but it is incredible
that this guy was so brilliant that he
was able to do this and by the way
with with a lot of these right wingers
it is incredible how they are very soft
on the violation of ukraine's border
integrity by russia while saying oh my
god when it comes to the u.s mexico
border we've got to have a border we've
got to enforce it there is nothing more
sacrosanct than the u.s mexico border
but the ukraine russia border it's sort
of up to putin's opinion where where
that should be
incredible this guy just loves these
authoritarian dictatorial autocrats and
you can hear it in his voice you can
hear it in his voice there's a little
bit of sarcasm and there's a little bit
of like uh wow what what how audacious
but it is a guy who is genuinely
impressed with the things vladimir putin
is doing he's
it's it's not a surprise it's not a
surprise if you're hearing something
different in trump's voice there
let me know you can find me on twitter
at dpakman
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes